TRAVEL TO THE REST OF THE WORLD.
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
ANSWERED.
SENATOR COTTON, THANK YOU.
AS OUR MONOLOGUE CONTINUES
TONIGHT, MUCH TO GET TO.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS WHAT IS THE
REVOLTING, REPULSIVE AND SADLY
PREDICTABLE BEHAVIOR FROM TWO
GROUPS OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE SAME TO PREDICTABLE GROUPS.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS ARE WORKING NIGHT AND
DAY, DAY AND NIGHT TOGETHER TO
BEAT BACK THIS NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND PANDEMIC.
THESE TWO HATE FILLED GROUPS
USING WHAT IS A DISEASE
ANTIVIRUS AT AN IMPORTANT MOMENT
TO SAVE LIVES AS A POLITICAL
WEAPON.
THE DOG BITES, THE BEE STINGS,
IF YOU ARE FEELING SADNESS/OUT
AT DONALD TRUMP.
TONIGHT’S EXAMPLE COMES FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI.
SHE JUST AUTHORED WHAT IS
NOTHING SHORT OF A BIZARRE,
REACH FILLED TRUMP OBSESSIVE
RANT WHICH IS FULL OF OUTRIGHT
LIES, OFFENDING HYPOCRISY,
BREATHTAKING, OUT OF TOUCH
REALITY FROM HER PART.
ED ACCORDING TO THE SPEAKER
AFTER AN EASTER WEEKEND FULL OF
DEEP PRAYER AND REFLECTION.
THAT USUALLY SETS YOU UP FOR,
OKAY, WHAT’S NEXT?
GOD APPARENTLY COMMUNICATED TO
HER THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CARNAGE
CAUSED BY CORONAVIRUS.
WRITING, "IN JANUARY
DONALD TRUMP WAS WARNED ABOUT
THIS PANDEMIC.
IGNORED THOSE MORNINGS AND TOOK
INSUFFICIENT ACTION, CAUSED
UNNECESSARY DEATH AND DISASTER.
OKAY, LET’S LET TRUTH GET IN THE
WAY OF HER LITTLE NARRATIVE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT CHINA DIDN’T IDENTIFY THE
CORONAVIRUS UNTIL JANUARY 9TH.
THE FIRST KNOWN CASE IN THE
UNITED STATES WAS JANUARY 21ST.
TEN DAYS LATER IN RECORD TIME,
CONTROVERSIAL AT THE MOMENT,
HYSTERIA, XENOPHOBIC,
FEARMONGERING RACIST,
JANUARY 31ST.
TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST CASE IN
THE U.S. DONALD TRUMP IMPLEMENT
TO THE TRAVEL BAN.
AND REMEMBER, MANDATORY
QUARANTINES, FIRST TIME IN OVER
50 YEARS.
SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL BANDS,
DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT NOBODY IN
THE HISTORY OF MODERN MEDICINE
INTERSECTING WITH POLITICS HAS
EVER ACTED FASTER.
WHAT WAS NANCY PELOSI DOING IN
JANUARY?
SPENDING EVERY WAKING MOMENT
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT.
THEN JANUARY 15, 5 DAYS AFTER
THE WORLD WAS WARNED ABOUT COBIT
19 SHE WAS ALL SMILES.
SHE SIGNED OFF ON HER
IMPEACHMENT SHIFT SHOW STUNT
WITH SELFIES, SMILES AND
PICTURES.
SHE KNEW THE IMPEACHMENT
WITCH HUNT WAS DEAD ON ARRIVAL
AND THE SENATE YET ALL
OF JANUARY AND INTO FEBRUARY,
THAT WAS WHAT THE FOCUS OF HER
ATTENTION WAS ON.
NOTHING ABOUT COBIT 19.
IN EARLY FEBRUARY AS A
PRESIDENT MENTIONED IT TO
CORONAVIRUS IN THE STATE OF THE
UNION, SCENE?
PELOSI ACTING BIZARRE AND PRETTY
RIPPING THE SPEECH WHILE THE
PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ALL ABOUT,
IN SOME CASES, CORONAVIRUS?
THIS WAS HER PREPLANNED MADE FOR
PUBLIC TV TEMPER TANTRUM
SIDESHOW.
THEN FEBRUARY 24, 1 MONTH AFTER
TRUMP’S TRAVEL BAN.
WELL INTO THIS HEALTH EMERGENCY,
PELOSI SHOWS UP FOR A PUBLICITY
STUNT ON THE CREDITS STREETS OF
CHINATOWN.
SHE’S HUGGING AND SHAKING HANDS
WITH SUPPORTERS ENCOURAGING
EVERYONE TO COME TO CHINATOWN
SAYING EVERYTHING IS FINE.
TURNS OUT IT WAS PELOSI WHO WAS
GIVING OUT FALSE INFORMATION.
IT WAS LOSEY WHO FAILED TO TAKE
ACTION.
IT WAS PELOSI WHO FAILED TO LEAD
AND IT WAS PELOSI WHO WAS SO
UPSET WITH IMPEACHMENT AND HER
STUNT AT THE STATE OF THE UNION
THAT SHE COULDN’T SEE THE FOREST
THROUGH THE TREES.
WHAT COULD EASILY BE A MOMENT OF
SELF REFLECTION AT THE END OF
PELOSI’S PRAYERS AND HER
RANTING, SHE WRITES "A WEAK
PERSON, A POOR LEADER TAKES NO
RESPONSIBILITY.
A WEAK PERSON BLAMES OTHERS.
YOU ARE THAT PERSON, YOU ARE
THAT POOR LEADER.
YOU ARE THE REASON THAT
AMERICANS HATE CAREER
POLITICIANS.
EVEN THE MIDDLE OF A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND PANDEMIC, PELOSI
PUTS POLITICS LIKE EVERY OTHER
GRANT, GIVE THEM BEFORE ANYONE